welcome to this video playing Hester
best he had a Norway flag once but
changed it to what is this like trinidad
and tobago or something he had his I
came get a Ben Oni here modern benoni
has star best or service okay I had
quite good results with this or let's
say I'm not sure about the results but
my positions tend to be very good with
this line so I'm continuing to play that
yeah yeah this is the case where a bit
of a yeah a taste and chest comes into
consideration I simply don't think that
this is any good as age 5 and so on I
don't know but more dynamic player or
whatever you may call it play and writer
might disagree ok so I'll out b5 was I
was it wise to do that not sure
yeah it very often is not such a big
issue but I didn't do it willingly I
have 19 20 or so I'm not I'm not totally
convinced that this is so bad I mean how
is he ever going to get the ammonia's
position here on with this king and so
on with the power on edge form okay if i
play Knight c4 I mean I have Bishop g5
okay let's let's think about it for a
moment I can also play here and threaten
94 let's try to play play some good
moves for a change and really punish
this okay the form is covered so I must
must go here definitely and now f4
probably we have four is this good in
this precise at this plus i have Knight
b6 also and then f 4 which is actually
quite strong this is this is almost all
most devastating isn't it I he needs to
give up some material now already i
think in some way I mean I'm going for
Bishop takes h5 here next that looks
really a really atrocious or i can just
drop back to see for which would be a
also strategically speaking a fantastic
yeah i'm not sure where to take i'm
going to take the bishop but i'm not
sure about it
so it could have taken the night okay so
now do is playing this hill Maria tech
lost last idea maybe Knight to g4
getting getting this quickly into
attacking positions night h6 is one move
I can just take here 986 HH six takes
Queen chicks that's probably not very
convincing I can just take here h4 is
also hanging I mean now the check is got
a king age 7 so I just take take yet
another pawn check okay this is somehow
not winning yet he's got queen takes a
higher coming up I have I'm really am
very a huge talent and miss playing
those totally winning positions this
isn't clear even this isn't totally
clear don't have a very good piece
coordination
doesn't even take amazing
interesting
that was probably strong I don't really
see anything right here how do i get
coordination going here Queen into
attacking v6 queen bee 6 may be very
tough very tough position we're okay hm
I've got a good age three okay I'm going
to play that check Wow I have no idea
what's going on here absolutely none
look B 1 and B 3 would be nice if I get
this in c3 now I can take so maybe
Bishop g5 coming okay let's cover it
time warning okay you should get some
thread in myself
d 2i can take c2 not sure what I'm going
to do okay I need to push my stuff as
well
check check check fh how does he prevent
it folksy 8 the c7.r I guess my points
are quicker
black resins pull this serve was one of
those games where I really thought I
would spoil it again I mean okay here
yeah it's it's completely winning but I
didn't play the most convincing way I
mean maybe this is a not good I can also
start with this and now now return this
is the comb suggestion man this looks
very strong actually keeping this on
this on the board the night on c4 and
those pieces are not really any good he
goes Knight f6 I can plainly five and
black is totally totally blasted from
the board right looking at this position
like this is really somewhat ridiculous
with those pawns yeah that's a total win
that's a total win yeah around here
blacks position is already very critical
compass on +1 it is difficult to keep
all those weak spots together h4n c4
here it gets very tricky I mean this is
I thought he maybe should try to give up
something here but yeah that's no better
move really and then look behind okay
the way I played it I grabbed some
material but he had definite counter
play here I must play a 5 yeah this is
really obvious in retrospect to prevent
his f5 and here I mean this was okay
night h6 better check yeah this is
probably
said it's only upon form if you look at
the the comp and here this isn't not
clear at all absolutely not clear even
the simple Queen f5 was was quite good
check amazing I totally miss played it
and she it gets very difficult c3 is
good for black now at least a slight
edge and I'll computers going up yeah it
looks dangerous for wide I'm not
coordinated well my background is weak
and everything c3 takes probably an
tides that that's a very very bad very
very very tough to play rook 'he was
given by the Machine Man and this is not
a move I would like to play he played
this and then went for the Queen trade
young hard to very hard to evaluate I
was surprised though that here he could
have played rookie aid I thought I
expected this move something like this
and he has still has this excellent
chance is here on the back rank with
still the pawns here I mean okay okay
his two pawns down but what is the comp
availab equal so he has excellent
compensation this was at least easy I
now I get to keep my pawns now they'll
know it term its its wings to him a wide
advantage yarn up and down up and down
now I'm okay but yet he gives a wide a
very good position Bishop g5 is not good
though we should be two is better why
okay this is yeah this is one of those
little tactical moves that I that are
tough to play when you don't have much
time he cannot play here because because
of this check in my e porn good promote
it's quite nice
ok and here it is equal again according
to the comp C 2 now wins for black yeah
it's tough it's very tough now I'm
winning again with my pocket check check
no I very complicated to a complicated
game but I really let him escape ok
thanks for watching